here we will talk about the calculation
of angular momentum people often forget
the angular momentum can be calculated
for any object even for an object that's
traveling in a straight line and not
rotating at all for example here I have
an object with mass M moving at a speed
V along a straight line another
important thing to keep in mind is that
angular momentum does not have a
definite value it depends on the choice
of origin which is arbitrary although
some choices are easier to calculate or
more useful than others
here I will choose this completely
random point to be my origin notice that
it can be any point in space angular
momentum is a lot like torque they both
involve a cross product of a distance
vector with another vector for angular
momentum it's the distance vector R the
vector from the origin to the object
cross P the momentum of the object or mV
once again we can write the magnitude of
this cross product as R times M V times
the sine of the theta between the two
but it's moral it's often more helpful
to think about this as R times sine
theta times MV in other words the R sine
theta is the component of the position
vector that's perpendicular to the
direction of the momentum let's practice
with a few other examples if I have a
ball moving up and I have my origin at
the side then this is the perpendicular
distance so the angular momentum is our
perpendicular times MV a reference point
that's the same horizontal distance away
from the object will see the same
angular momentum notice that in this
case the angular momentum is not
changing as the ball moves because the
perpendicular distance is not changing
with time in this case if the ball is
moving at an angle we again have to take
the perpendicular component of the
position vector to find the angular
momentum this second reference point is
now a different distance of
so the angular momentum is larger now
let's talk about the sine of angular
momentum you can calculate the sign of a
cross product with the right-hand rule
make sure your vectors are tail to tail
when you compare the directions so in
this case we have that R cross V points
into the page in the case of circular
motion R and V are always perpendicular
so we can just multiply the magnitudes
together and the sign tells us which way
we are going around the circle if we
consider out of the page to be positive
and the angular momentum is positive
then the object is circulating
counterclockwise if the angular momentum
is negative the object is circulating
clockwise